- Good evening, everyone,
and welcome here for
this wonderful session
on how many of our esteemed clients here
are gonna be putting AI at
the core of transformation.
So we are very privileged
to have this opportunity
to be sharing a bunch
of our client stories
on how we worked together
with some of these clients
and they've transformed
their enterprises using AI.
With me today, you're gonna
see a set of speakers.
We're gonna first invite Keisha Garcia.
Keisha Garcia is with BP.
She's a VP for Digital
Enterprise Platforms and Systems.
Following Keisha, you're
gonna hear Srini Upadhyaya.
Srini is with Transamerica,
and he's Head of Business Services.
Following Srini, you're
gonna see, we had Chaitanya,
but then Chaitanya had to leave
because of a personal emergency,
so we're gonna have Sada come over.
Sada is with Hertz,
and he's the SVP for Platform Engineering.
And last but not the least
is Krishna Srinivasan.
Krishna is with United Airlines.
He's the Director of
Architecture, Cloud, and DevOps.
So before we hand over to each
of these esteemed speakers
and have them share their stories
of how they've gone through
this transformation,
I want to take a minute
to talk about how Infosys sees this space.
So we're looking at three
stages of transformation.
We've seen a lot of our clients...
We've gone through this
transformation ourselves,
and we've seen a lot of our clients
go through this transformation.
Stage one is really making
their enterprises more digital,
how have they all embraced cloud.
So we are at AWS re:Invent,
and a lot of us are thankful for AWS
for all the capabilities
that they've delivered
that's enabled our clients to be,
that have made them more
resilient and more scalable.
The second stage of transformation
is really about how they've made,
created composable capabilities,
how have they got
enterprises ready for AI.
So how did they get
their data ready for AI,
how did they build capabilities,
how did they modernize
all of their platforms
that's enabled them to drive
a lot of business experiences.
Third stage is all about
all the experiences that you've seen.
You're gonna hear some
very interesting stories
from each one of them
on how all of these capabilities
have enabled some very
interesting experiences
for their customers,
within their enterprise,
and with their supply chain.
So without much ado,
what I wanna do is to invite
our first speaker, Keisha.
Keisha, why don't you
come on stage. Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you, and thank
you for having me here
to talk through our
journey with you, with us.
So BP is navigating one of our
most profound transformations
and transitions in the energy industry,
balancing both reliability
with sustainability,
as well as leveraging technology
and driving innovation
to deliver energy for today and tomorrow.
So BP is one of the world's
leading integrated energy companies,
and we operate in over
61 different countries,
with a workforce of over 100,000+ people,
and our heritage dates
back to as far as 1908.
And BP, where we are today,
we're focusing today,
is delivering our energy
safely, as well as reliably,
and increasingly lowering
our carbon intensity.
So our scale matters,
and 21,200 retail sites is
what we have with the scale,
as well as 39,000 EV charging points,
and 2.4 million barrels
of oil equivalent per day
in our upstream production.
So over a decade ago, BP
set out on a bold mission
that I had the privilege of
working with quite a few teams
to transform our digital
landscape with cloud,
and our cloud-first vision was back then
our footprint spanned over
eight mega data centers
hosting over 18,000 servers,
and today we've migrated
10,000+ applications,
and, I'm sorry, over 10,000+ applications,
and also we closed 27+ data
centers across the globe,
decommissioned over 15,000 servers,
as well as moved over one
petabyte of data to the cloud,
turning our vision into reality.
And now more than 93% of BP's
applications run in the cloud,
actually 95% as of today.
We've moved a few more.
So delivering speed, resilience,
as well as innovation at scale.
So this journey was never
just about technology.
Along the way, we embraced Agile, DevOps.
We modernized our platforms,
and we unlocked the power of data.
We reduced technical debt
by addressing our end of serviceable life.
We streamlined our processes,
we built the foundation
for what comes next
in our AI-first future,
and the cloud transformation program,
which is what it was called, CTP,
has not only modernized BP's IT estate,
but it ensured zero process safety,
or we also were able to get through that
with zero process safety events.
We strengthened our security,
and we created a resilient
digital core for the future.
So this achievement reflects
the collective effort
of BP's digital teams, our
businesses, our integrators,
and our enablers.
Our cloud journey is
proof of what's possible
when vision, as well as
action, comes together.
And now, as we step into the era of AI,
we are ready to unlock
even more potential,
driving innovation, sustainability,
as well as transformation
for BP and beyond.
So by moving to the cloud,
it's unlocked all of these capabilities,
and it's made what we thought
was impossible possible.
So the scale of our compute power
is to train and deploy
advanced AI models at speed,
centralize and secure data platforms
that enable real-time analytics
and predictive insights,
and modernize and develop
our development environments
that's faster, agile, DevOps,
and continuous innovation.
So our global collaboration tools
that empower talent to experiment, learn,
and innovate without boundaries,
as well as cloud has created a culture
where ideas can also take
shape and move faster,
teams work smarter, and the
data drives every decision.
It also enables our BP people
to harness all of our AI
capability for smarter operations,
optimize our energy systems,
and breakthrough solutions,
so accelerating our journey
towards our digital-first
and our sustainable future.
So when I think about how we're
driving innovation with AI,
so with our customers and products,
if I think about some of the examples,
for our customers, AI is
redefining what energy means.
It's personal, predictive, sustainable.
AI helps us forecast demand
so we can deliver the right
products at the right time.
It also powers our smart
mobility solutions,
ensuring EV drivers find charging stations
when they need them,
and it also gives our customers
the needs or the tools
that track and reduce
our carbon footprint.
So because innovation isn't
just about technology,
it's about trust as well,
and it's about trust with our customers.
So in our P and O, our
production and operations area,
on the front lines of production,
AI is our silent partner.
It predicts equipment failures
before they even happen.
It's saving millions, and
keeping our people safe.
It's optimizing drilling
and refining processes.
It's also squeezing the inefficiencies
and reducing our emissions.
Every sensor and every
data point becomes a voice,
and AI listens and learns,
and acts to make operations
smarter and safer.
So digital transformation
is a big part of our story,
and we are working with partners
like Microsoft and Palantir
to use AI to optimize and
to build digital twins,
as well as for predictive maintenance
and developing tech stacks
for sustainable aviation fuel,
as well as on the engineering side,
we're developing
remotely-operated platforms
and advanced seismic imaging
to also improve our efficiency and safety.
In our people and culture area,
our most powerful transformation
isn't in the machines,
it's in our people,
and AI is helping us upscale,
as well as upscale our workforce
and turning curiosity into capability.
It's also breaking down
barriers, fostering diversity,
as well as creating a culture
where innovation thrives.
So with AI, our teams collaborate faster,
we share knowledge,
we seamlessly make
decisions with confidence,
because technology without
people is just code, right?
So, but with people, it's revolution.
At BP, we're not just adapting AI,
we're shaping the future in energy,
as well as together we're building a world
that's safer, cleaner,
and we're more connected.
And this is more than
innovation; it's transformation.
So our vision for our drivers,
we accelerated our business transformation
through intelligent experimentation,
architectural leverage,
and our close partnerships
with our digital teams,
and our goal is to move beyond pilots,
improve measurable value first and fast,
and delivering capability
that's owned and scalable
and production-ready.
The journey ahead is really our strategy
is prioritizing immediate cost reduction
over the next 18 to 24 months,
which we've started well on that journey,
while building foundational
AI capabilities,
as well as building those capabilities
that are sustainable
and that gives us a competitive advantage.
So by adopting and giving a
surround and conquer approach,
we will first transform
our cost functions,
demonstrating clear and measurable ROI,
as well as drive broader
solutions and adoption
across our business units.
Success requires building
AI-savvy leadership,
as well as cost-focused talent,
and then also pragmatic
buy/build decisions.
We'll operate within the data and talent,
and we'll prioritize rapid savings
over slow, lengthy ROI processes,
but focusing on initiatives at
the 18-month payback or less.
We'll continuously evaluate
emerging technologies
through lean experiments
before significant investments,
and then those guiding principles
that's kind of like our North Star
is our business-driven attitude
with technology doesn't lead the way.
It's our people, it's
vision, and vision does.
Every AI initiative begins
with a clear business purpose,
and we're not just doing things
just for the sake of doing it.
We're looking at the value focus things.
We don't just chase the shiny objects,
although there are times where
we have to remind ourselves
that, again, getting ahead
of the curve is great,
but again, not chasing the shiny objects,
but starting with real
challenges, real pain points
that will solve what matters most for us.
So sometimes you have to look at it
with the "build it, and
they will come" mindset,
but only doing that, using that mindset
only for bold, high-potential bets.
That means when you're
dealing with AI ideas
that could fundamentally
reshape a workflow,
or create a new revenue stream,
or unlock a step change, efficiency,
something with genuine
transformational upside,
you sometimes do build
ahead of the proven demand,
but you take calculated leaps,
because the payoff is
worth the uncertainty,
and you look at it from a
risk-based approach as well.
So for everything else, you
earn adoption the hard way.
You validate the problem,
you test the demand,
and you prove ROI
pressure test feasibility.
So with that being said, and
I'm sorry I went on too fast,
those are the things
that we are doing at BP
to help prove out all of the
things that we need to do.
We're looking at the
routine automation ideas
that must earn its business
case before you build it.
As I said, even though you
do the build versus buy,
but also on the fact of those
moonshot predictive systems
that could change how the
entire asset class is run,
we must justify building early
and iterating into the demand.
So as I said, the discipline around ROI
has to be there, though,
so the ambition matters,
but outcomes matter more,
and every initiative must
drive measurable impact.
And we commit to tracking performance.
We are committing to
learning from those results,
improving value.
But also, because transformation
without accountability
isn't transformation at all,
you have to be able to operate
it and also track those ROIs.
So our cost function, first,
is our target finance,
our HRIT, for immediate
improvements in bottom line.
And then from a build
shared infrastructure
to avoid vendor lock-in
and build muscle for later,
and strategic bets.
And then also from an automation
and offshoring perspective,
accelerate our AI automation
instead of solely relying
on labor arbitrage,
as well as data AI synopsis,
using AI to solve our data
quality as well as issues,
and not waiting for perfect data.
So again, our teams
are working really hard
to ensure that we're working together
with all of our partners to
do what we can to transform,
and driving and allowing our people
and our business goals and
our business aspirations
to get us there.
So that is what we're doing at BP,
and that is how AI is
really taking the forefront,
and the cloud transformation
helped to get us there
and set us up quite well
for what we're doing.
Thank you.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you.
Okay, good afternoon, everyone. Sorry.
Good afternoon, everyone. My
name is Srinivas Upadhyaya.
I'm the Head of Business Services
and Digital Technologies for Transamerica,
been there for like about six years.
For the first five years
I ran all of architecture engineering,
basically cloud as well
as cloud migration.
So again, super excited to be here
to talk about like, you know,
how we are accelerating our business value
using cloud and AI.
Where's the clicker?
So little bit of an intro on
like in Transamerica, right?
What do we do?
We offer a broad range of,
you know, kind of products,
life insurance, annuities,
and also retirement plans,
and also some other investment products.
Like, you know, again,
most of you are familiar
with our 401(k), 403(b),
like, you know, kind of IRA solutions.
We have about close to
10.7 million customers
all within U.S., and
about 7,000 employees.
So when we think about like
in our business applications,
as we went through this
modernization, right,
like, you know, there
were two main factors,
like, you know, agility,
and like, you know, kind
of delivering products
at a faster pace.
And now we are onto our AI
adoption journey, right?
So three main things
I want to like, you
know, kind of emphasize.
All of our retirement,
like, you know, kind of
record-keeping ecosystem,
that's like about 60% of our workloads.
You know, they're working in AWS Cloud.
We went through a major
transformation journey.
We also, like, you know, as
part of the modernization,
like, you know, built
two major data lakes,
again, one for retirement datasets,
and the other one for like,
you know, life and annuities.
And that actually is helping,
you know, kind of advance,
like, you know, whether it's BI-based,
like, you know, reporting insights,
or, you know, using AI, right?
And we are making strides there.
So this is an interesting slide, right?
Like, and again, like why?
You know, why this
transformation journey, right?
So there were four main
strategic priorities, right,
again, our global CIO laid out:
monetization, customer
centricity, simplification,
and like, you know, scalability
and like security, right?
So when we think about
like in a modernization,
this is all about like, you know,
we migrated all of our
retirement workloads,
we retired like in our
complete mainframe footprint,
you know, we converted to
like in a modern tech stack.
I'll talk about it a little bit.
And also with all of these
applications in the cloud,
as well as the data lake in the cloud,
we are able to like, you know,
kind of build products faster.
The other thing also, it's
a great benefit, right?
Like, you know, tech debt,
I know every company deals with it.
We were able to reduce,
like, you know, quite a bit of tech debt.
So the second is like, you know,
when it comes to customer centricity,
it's all about, like in
our digital journeys,
we want to really wow our customers
with better, like in our UI experiences.
And, you know, again, with
the data in the lakes,
we are able to, like, you know,
kind of take advantage of that,
and like, you know, build more
advanced insights using AI.
Then the third is simplification.
This is all about like, you know,
straight through processing,
as well as like, you
know, automation, right?
So we have about close to 300+
like, you know, kind of business services,
and another like, you know,
500+ business services
in the life and annuity
space total, right?
So again, you're constantly figuring out
how to like, you know,
kind of leverage those
to do straight through processing.
And we have also automated
all of our CI/CD DevOps,
like, you know, basically
pipelines, right?
So both from an infra and a code,
so we are able to like, you
know, do the deployments faster,
at least for the critical applications.
We also, like, you know, invested
in blue-green deployments,
right, so that way we are trying
to keep our, you know,
application downtime to minimal.
Then again, the last
strategic priority, right,
again, stability, scalability,
and like, you know, security, right?
So we are seeing like, you
know, improved performance.
Like actually,
when we went through the
whole batch migration, right?
Like, you know, a lot of
it is mainframe batch.
It's actually running
in like half the time,
like in as to what it used to be before.
Again, from a scaling, we take advantage
of like, you know, again,
auto-scaling capabilities,
of course, like, you
know, variable pricing.
That's always, like, you know, great.
And then in terms of security, again,
a lot of the security features,
you know, kind of network segmentation,
you know, again, advanced
access management features,
and also being able to like,
you know, kind of be stable,
like in, again, multi-AZ,
multi-region support,
we are able to like, you
know, take advantage of it.
Just the retirement ecosystem,
you can see the scope.
It's like about 100, 120 applications,
about 400, you know, kind of services,
and we have about, like, you
know, 4,000 batch workloads,
out of which at least 1,000 of them
are like in our kind of
COBOL mainframe base,
and 400+ terabytes of data.
And in terms of the mainframe,
the code that was converted,
it was almost close to 2.3
to 2.5 million lines of code.
We transformed all of
the COBOL code to Java,
and, you know, again, the whole migration,
end to end, start to finish,
like, you know, we did
it in 2.5 years, right,
two and a half years.
Again, Infosys was our
implementation partner.
Great, great, like, you know,
I would say partnership.
So next slide. So this is
an interesting slide, right?
Like, you know, it's like you can see
this is nothing but like technology stack,
like, you know, before and after.
As you can see, you know,
before, you know, pretty
much like older versions
of Java, .NET,
this is a tech debt stuff
I was talking about,
you know, C, C++, Python,
.NET, older versions,
or compute was, like, you
know, VMs or physicals,
but older versions of like,
you know, kind of VMware tech,
all of the runtime technologies,
like, you know, WebLogic,
JBoss, TOMCAT, you name it, right,
like in very old versions.
And, you know, we had like,
you know, whole flavors
of like, you know, database technologies,
you know, Oracle, SQL Server, DB2,
and, you know, once the migration,
we kind of like, you know,
went through it, right,
like, you know, again, we
were able to take advantage
of Amazon Corretto Java,
you know, upgraded versions
of like, you know, all
of the .NET, Angular,
compute, again, ECS, EKS,
Fargate, you know, Lambda.
And also we upgraded
a lot of our runtime
platforms versions too.
And from a databases, again,
we are heavily leveraging,
like in RDS.
I'll talk a little bit
about the mainframe stuff.
On the mainframe, again,
on the left side, you can see, right?
COBOL, CICS, JCL, DB2, like,
you know, again, on z/OS.
So a lot of the CICS screens,
like, you know, your batch workloads,
everything was sitting
on a huge mainframe box.
It's like almost consuming
14,000 MIPS at any point of time,
to, we actually used AWS Blu Age.
I think there's a name change.
It's called AWS, like,
you know, Transform now,
but, you know, it's like, you
know, it's an amazing tool.
So we went through that,
the entire conversion to the mainframe
in less than, like, you
know, 12 months, right?
So the final cutover was
on June 9th last year.
We went from 14,000 MIPS
to like, you know, like six
or seven MIPS just right away,
right, after that conversion.
Again, just from a technology stack,
you know, after the conversion, right,
we are leveraging, again,
Amazon Corretto Java,
all of the CICS screens that
were, you know, previously run
on, like, you know, kind of mainframe,
like, you know, we, you
know, kind of replaced them
with Angular, Spring Boot, and
also DB2 z/OS to DB2 Linux.
That's like, you know,
was our conversion path.
And we are leveraging quite a bit
of like, you know, RDS
technologies as well, right?
And as I mentioned, about close
to 2.5 million lines of code
with the AWS Blu Age,
we kind of converted it.
And also in the process, right,
we developed about close
to 7,000+ functional
and regression test feed, right?
So it's automated, now
it's part of our arsenal,
so anytime there's a major release,
we can actually quickly run that,
like, you know, make
sure nothing's broken,
especially for the batch, right?
Because the nightly batch,
that's when like, you know,
you're basically selling and buying,
you know, mutual funds,
ETFs, so ETFs and all,
it's actually pretty intense
in terms of how many billions of dollars,
like, you know, more every night.
So we did about close to
100+ parallel test runs,
especially for our batch workloads
with different datasets, right?
Like, you know, we use datasets,
like, you know, whether
it's daily, weekly,
you know, tax day datasets,
your monthly, quarterly,
yearly, your peak volumes,
you name it, right?
So this is, again, we do a lot
of customer reference calls,
and all of this stuff, references.
This is like, you know, a little bit
of like, you know, lessons learned, right?
Like, you know, if you are
going through this journey,
you'll find this really useful, right?
The first one is data gravity,
right? Think about it.
Like in a lot of these
application services,
they're so intertwined, right?
So, and of course you're not gonna be able
to do the whole thing
big bang, just by itself,
so we did about 800 releases
in like two and a half years.
So pay attention to data gravity.
What it means is like, you
know, you need to understand
what are the interdependencies
so that you can bundle the
applications logically,
so that way, you know what,
you don't have, like, you
know, your database on-prem
and the rest of the services in cloud.
So now with the latency,
you have performance issues
and all this stuff, right?
You need to really pay attention to it.
With the Blu Age thing,
when we went through this
whole mass migration,
they actually do something pretty cool
called calibration phase, right?
So what the calibration phase
really is, you take a sample,
you can take probably like,
you know, 100 batch jobs,
like, you know, 30, 40 CICS screens,
they'll run it through the calibration,
and they'll tell you,
like, you know, how easy or hard it is,
like, you know, for the conversion, right?
So that way you can know
for your entire scale,
what is it that you're
getting into, right?
That was really helpful.
Like I said, testing, testing,
testing, parallel testing,
we invested quite a bit.
So actually one of the things is
we did like for the
last mainframe migration
cutover on June 9th.
Prior to that we did three,
what we called as mock runs, right?
So think about it like
the entire mainframe
and the rest of the application services,
the whole ecosystems,
including the satellite databases
and everything like that,
we flipped in production,
you know, over a weekend,
and then we used to flip back, right?
So, and again, there's a lot
of testing that happened.
So that way for the first mock run,
when we ran it, we had
about 100 bugs, right?
This is after all the other
crazy testing we went through.
And then after the second one,
we kind of like, you know, ended
up with like maybe 60 bugs.
The third one, we brought it down
to like, you know, almost nil,
and then the final one,
like, you know, was the
real cutover, right?
So we invested quite a bit on that.
The other thing, so,
like, you know, again,
talent upskilling, think about it, right?
Like, you know, insurance industry,
a lot of times there's a
lot of legacy tech folks
invest in like, you know,
kind of training them up,
but also at the same time,
we had Infosys as our
implementation partner.
It was awesome partnership, as I said.
Software rationalization.
Think about it this way, right?
A lot of your on-prem contracts,
software contracts, right,
you gotta really see, like, you know,
how they can be translated to AWS, right?
Like, so we invested, it was
like almost like six months
with working with
procurement on all of that
so that we know,
especially for the
budgeting purposes, right,
you know, what that means.
Communication, this is
extremely important.
You need to like, you know, make sure
you have alignment with
your business partners,
because think about it, right?
It's a long journey,
and along this journey,
of course they're gonna continue
to like, build, you know, new products
and all of this stuff, right,
and a lot of times there's coalitions,
you need your own blackout
periods, and all of this stuff.
They'll say that, "Hey, the
products are more important.
We gotta like, you know,
keep our revenues going,"
and all this stuff.
So having that alignment,
and continuing to like, you
know, explain the benefits
of like, you know, this
migration, that goes a long way,
especially like, you
know, they're the ones
who are really gonna help
you with the UAT testing
and whatnot, right?
So that really helped out.
Actually, one other thing I
wanna say is like, you know,
just in terms of how this
is getting translated
to like, you know, AI, right?
Again, we are, you know, we use Copilot
like all of our employees,
like, you know, they have
Copilot for their tasks.
You know, we are heavily invested
in like, you know, kind of Amazon Q
for our software developers,
and we are using other techniques
to like, you know, for building
the regression test cases
and all of that stuff,
and the best part is like, you know, now
with the data lakes in cloud,
we are continuously,
like, you know, trying
to like, you know, kind of hydrate those
with the newer datasets
and all of this stuff,
it's becoming so much better for us
to like, you know, kind of
be on the AI journey, right?
Again, it's still a journey.
We have about 10 or 15 use cases
that we are, you know,
taking advantage of,
but most importantly, like, you know,
it's an awesome journey.
We don't have to worry
about the foundation,
because the cloud and the data,
that foundation has been
established already.
So again, thank you, Infosys.
I know IBM, like, you
know, they helped us,
like, you know, with the z/OS DB2
to like, you know, DB2
Linux conversion as well,
and incredible like, you know,
Transamerica team, right?
And thank you for listening
to our story. I appreciate it.
(audience applauding)
- A big hand to Srinivas and
Keisha for a job well done.
(audience applauding)
Let me walk you through our journey.
I'll go what happened four years back.
I'll talk about the present,
and I'll talk about the next two years.
I don't think I can
read the next two years,
but I'll certainly try to
read the next two years.
My name is Sada Iyer.
As it says, I'm the SVP
of Technology at Hertz.
When I joined four years ago,
I was literally given a playbook,
a playbook with end of
life, end of support,
incidents happening on a daily basis.
And guess what? I'll use a car analogy.
My job was how do I change the tires
of a running car, right?
So that was the challenge
that was given to me.
Before I continue too much
further, I work for Hertz,
so I'm gonna ask a quiz, right?
I'll give you four options.
Hertz is in the car rental
business, Hertz sells cars,
Hertz partners with Uber and Lyft,
and number four, Hertz
sells cars on Amazon.
If I give you an option,
option A, which is Hertz,
the car rental company,
by show of hands, how many
want to raise their hands?
If I tell you that Hertz does
all the four, show of hands.
So did you know that Hertz
actually sells cars on Amazon?
So tomorrow when you go home
and you're shopping for
your milk and your bread
and your supplies, go and
shop for a car on Amazon.
(chuckling) Again, before
I fo go too much into it,
I need to thank my team.
Without my team that have stood besides me
for the last four years,
I would've not been where I'm today.
That's not me.
Yeah.
So if you look at the references
that I've got on the slide,
it's all about voyage,
tune-up, the wrenching, right,
the journey.
But like I said, four
years ago where I started,
we had a high cost of standing still.
End of life services, end
of life hardware, software,
like I said, incidents happening,
and we had two choices.
Either we invest in the data center,
or we do it all-in migration to the cloud.
And guess what did we choose?
We chose an all-in migration
to the cloud, right?
It was not an easy feat.
We had HP-UX, critical
applications running on HP-UX.
What did we do?
Working with Amazon,
we actually ran it on
emulation software in AWS,
so that's working fine.
Our second challenge was
how do you scale our applications, right?
I'm gonna throw a number,
3,000 TPS on the front end.
When you think about 3,000
TPS on the front end,
it's not a big number, right?
But the backend was not able
to go more than 5,000
transactions per second.
So our first order of magnitude was
how do we scale the backend,
and that's what we did, right?
That backend was extremely critical.
It's running COBOL on Micro Focus Linux.
Micro Focus COBOL on Linux, right,
and therefore we were
able to migrate to AWS.
Not only did we scale the
application horizontally,
but we also scaled the application
from an application sharding perspective.
So I'm giving you pointers
in terms of what we did
so you can decide on whether
it's gonna be helpful for you
in the future.
As we were doing that migration,
the third one was what we
call our rates ecosystem.
We have one master, and on a daily basis
it's about 1.6 billion
rates requests per day.
So as you can imagine, we had
to scale our rates ecosystem.
And what's a rate?
If you go to shop on hertz.com,
and you go and look for a shop,
and it pulls up a given,
let's say, Nissan or a Toyota,
there's a rate along with it, right?
That's the rate request
that I'm talking about,
about 1.6 billion rate request per day.
Yes, we were using Oracle,
yes, we are still using Oracle,
and we had to figure out
a way to scale, right?
And we had to scale with low latency.
So at any given point in time
we have about 16 to 20
replicas running in AWS.
So again, that was a migration
that we had to take care of.
So if you look, if you think
about the journey that we did,
it about took about two and a half years
of all-in migration to AWS.
Fast forward to today, earlier this year,
you know, you learn from your failures,
you learn from your mistakes.
A developer, unfortunately
he did something wrong
in production environment.
And guess what? It brought our
production environment down.
And that's the reason we built
what we call blue-green stacks
or active-passive environment, right?
Now we have, in a single region,
active-passive environment.
With few incidents that have happened
over the last few weeks,
we are also planning to
have multi-region stack
running in AWS, right?
So that's our journey.
If you think about from an AI perspective,
obviously we are using GitHub, Copilot,
we are using Bedrock,
and if you think about where
we are using AWS Bedrock,
it's all about our...
When a customer calls with
a problem, with a complaint,
we are using AWS Transcribe,
we are using AWS Bedrock
to figure out, okay, why is
the customer calling, right?
And typically it's about,
"Oh, where is my invoice?"
or, "I have a flat tire," right?
So we are trying to see the reasons
why the customers are calling
and make it easier for the customer
to be able to transact with
Hertz on a day-to-day basis.
So where are we right now?
We are on a journey to
modernize legacy platforms.
And let me tell you a story.
About six months back,
my CIO at that time,
and we traveled about
four cities in five days,
in three different locations.
We actually met four partners,
and each and every partner
was given the same problem.
Take this 10 pieces of COBOL program
and tell me how you are convert it.
These COBOL programs were
running on the NonStop, right?
And I think you might have
heard about HPE NonStop,
or it's also called the Tandem.
These programs were
running on the NonStop.
Three partners, three
vendors give the typical,
"Oh, we will do analysis,
we will do design,
we'll do unit testing, we'll do..."
I'm like, "No, that's not of interest."
The day we walked into Infosys office,
in the first one hour,
they showed me a working
prototype working model
of the converted code, right?
No presentations. I was
not interested in PPTs.
I wanted to see a working model, right?
And that is what actually impressed us
to partner with Infosys.
So if you think about what we did,
they have a platform called iLead.
iLead helped us do the documentation.
These programs have been existing
for the last 20, 25 years, right?
As you can imagine,
and NonStop has been in
operation for the last 25 years.
Documentation doesn't exist.
Nobody knows why a program was written.
Nobody knows how to test a
migrated COBOL program, right?
Nobody knows what scale to test it at.
So the documentation
actually helped me big time
to say, "Program A talks to
program B, talks to program C."
It also showed me the
database dependencies,
the table dependencies, right?
So in one sheet of paper, I could now see
that a given program,
what it was dependent on,
as well as the tables.
So obviously we had a part of a journey
where we are migrating,
we are about six months into a journey.
Without the iLead platform,
I think we were taking
about four years to convert.
With the iLead platform,
I think we are targeting about 18 months.
We are expecting production
drops every month starting now,
with our development
complete by end of March.
We are gonna spend a
significant amount of time
in shadow testing, right,
making sure that the data in production
in the NonStop environment,
data in the converted actually matches.
And until we do shadow testing,
and they'll only then give
it to the users who test it,
we'll not plan to go live.
But as of now, all indicators
are we are on track to go live
by end of Q3,
and that's a critical timeline for us
because of our contract reasons, right?
So we are marching towards it.
If you look at the last bullet website,
it's a partnership-driven model, right?
We didn't want to go to a vendor
that were going to be task takers.
We wanted some thought leadership.
Maybe I got lucky.
I got a good team of architects,
I got a good team of test people
that were actually came
with the thought leadership,
which is why we are partnering
with Infosys on this journey.
So if you think about what's next for us
in terms of summary,
it's called reading the old manuals,
which is reading the
old COBOL codes, right?
It's talking about writing.
So not only did the iLead platform
did the reverse engineering,
not only did the iLead
platform did the discovery
and the dependencies,
it also did the forward
engineering, right?
And the forward engineering
adheres to a template.
The template is based on
your specifications, right?
If you say, "These are
my coding standards,
these are my coding guidelines,"
it adheres to that template, right,
which is extremely critical.
So in terms of what I think
the future holds for us,
I personally think that all the things
from an AI perspective,
what are the things that
we don't like to do?
Number one, documentation.
There's no engineer in this
world who likes to do document.
I think we can probably have an agent
that does documentation.
What's the second thing
that we don't like to do?
Testing, right? We think we
write the best code, right?
Guess what?
I'm thinking there's gonna be an agent
that's gonna help us test.
Third, observability, right?
We don't like to implement metrics, right?
And obviously integration with PagerDuty,
I think we can have an
agent for doing that, right?
So those are the areas that I'm exploring.
Also from an incident response standpoint.
Look at the amount of
logs we are generating.
I'm anticipating an agent
that's going to help me
mine through all my logs
and be proactive about when
an incident is gonna happen,
right?
So when I think about the possibilities,
yes, there's this fear about
AI replacing jobs, right?
I think that it's a time for us
to go deep in a specific skill,
because AI can replace general skillset
but not deep skillsets, right?
Managing...
How many of you are knowledgeable
about EKS, Amazon EKS?
Show of hands? Right?
Yes, AWS did a pretty good job
of keeping the control plane
out of your sight, right,
and you are only dealing with pods
and deploying out on nodes.
But when things go wrong, guess what?
You need your kubectl commands, right?
So you need your expertise,
whether it's a service services,
whether it's a node port
service, ingress service,
you need to know your technical knowledge
to be able to interpret what
AI is telling you, right?
So in closing, thanks to my team,
thanks to Infosys for the partnership.
The thing that I always ask myself is,
whenever you have a challenge at hand,
whether it's test automation,
whether it's documentation,
ask the question, what can AI do for you?
Thank you very much.
(audience applauding)
- Thanks, Sada. Good afternoon, everyone.
So I'm Krishna Srinivasan,
a director at United
responsible for enterprise
architecture, cloud, and DevOps.
And before I get into this,
just wanted a show of hands,
how many of you guys flew
United for coming to re:Invent?
Thank you very much, guys.
For guys who haven't flown
on United, please try.
You'll have a wonderful experience.
So as many of you know,
United is one of the largest airline,
or not one of the, it's the
largest airline in the world,
and our mission every
day is to connect people,
unite the world.
And like we do this at
a very massive scale.
And like we fly about like
more than 2,000 aircrafts
to 360 destinations,
and like carrying over 175
million customers every year.
That's about half a million
customers every day.
And then like we have
about 107k employees,
talented professionals that
are working hard every day
to make sure our customers
are getting to their destinations safely.
So on the systems side,
the technology landscape
is complex and very intricate, right?
So we have complex integrations
of our modern systems
with our legacy systems.
We have a big legacy footprint.
So we have a global infrastructure
in airports, data center,
cloud, all over the place
and orchestrations through
4,000 APIs, 300 business events.
And like we are registering transactions
about 5 billion hits on
our digital channels,
and 1 billion events
on the backend operational systems, right?
So that's the scale.
And this is what enables United
to be able to deliver that
exceptional customer service
that each and every one
of you deserve, right,
all of our customers deserve.
And United has demonstrated
remarkable, like adaptability,
like reinventing itself multiple times
through a lot of the
technology revolutions,
through economic upheavals,
like the pandemics, like global events,
and each and every time coming out
establishing itself as the
pioneer in commercial aviation.
So, just like how like we saw Sada
use some of the car lingo,
the car rental lingo,
I'm gonna use the airline lingo, right?
So our flight plan for
digital transformation
started with cloud-first.
Cloud-first, right?
So we started looking into cloud-first
for building any new capabilities,
because we knew it was gonna
help us innovate, be nimble,
quickly react to changes,
and more, like, importantly,
run reliable operations.
So very quickly we realized
that like we needed
to start like automating repetitive tasks
so that we could kind of
like make the migrations,
modernizations more
efficient and effective.
And then like we end up,
and we started bringing in
modern integration platforms
like connecting these capabilities,
centralizing the data across
all of our business domains,
crew, operations, finance, HR,
and this set the stage for us
to be able to run AI/ML models,
and we started focusing on use cases
for optimizing our flight plan,
for like how much fuel
we put on the planes,
customer notifications.
And then like we started
seeing ourselves transform
into this AI-first enterprise,
where we started looking at AI,
embedding AI into everything
that we do, right?
Like everything we do, not
only like everything we do,
how we do too, we wanted to
start infusing AI into that.
And now, like we are kind
of like unlocking the power
of agentic AI for the compounding value.
We are gonna be getting out
of like this agentic AI,
as well as the human-in-the-loops
systems, right?
So when we started the journey to cloud,
obviously like coming from
a data center organization,
right, like it was with the
heavy mindset we got in there,
very quickly we learned
to start leveraging the AWS
well-architected framework,
the standards, best practices,
to start implementing it
the more like the cloud way, right?
But then, so we started seeing
varying implementations,
right, like different
tool sets being used,
like different like deployment
strategies being used, right?
Like there was like a lot of
things all over the place.
That's where like we
engaged a strategic partner
like Infosys to help us start
creating the building blocks,
right, like the foundational blocks
for how we would enable the teams
to be building cloud workloads
in a much reliable, secure way, right?
So what we did is we
created a tool set, right?
Like we coined this program as Cloud 3.0.
Basically we took out,
we started creating the
reference architectures
for the design patterns.
We started templatizing them,
and like we made this
open source for people,
for teams to contribute back to this,
so that helped with that option.
And then like we started
building starter kits
so teams could take this to
kind of set up their environment
and start getting into
kind of coding, right?
And then we started giving
them all these power packs
for observability, for
like doing their recovery,
like region failovers.
And also we wanted to
embed like the practices,
so we started building kits
for the teams to be able
to integrate chaos testing
as part of the pipeline, right?
So this pretty much helped us.
So this helped us
like accelerate our
transformation to cloud.
So today we have 60%,
more than 60% of our
like mission critical,
business critical workloads in cloud.
And also like teams using the starter kits
were able to get it done much faster,
15% faster going from
design to development,
development to deployment.
And then like this also
had a very positive impact
on our MTTR, and we were
able to see a 7% reduction,
which we were able to attribute
to these like this
resiliency, the recovery,
like solutions that we had
to quickly record service
moving to another region, right?
So this basically helped
us set the stage, right?
So not only we started
building consistently,
but we started building
faster, very secure,
reliable, scalable workloads,
and this basically kind of
set the foundation for us
to be able to layer the
AI strategy on top of it.
So our strategy on AI is everyday AI.
It keep our employees
with AI capabilities,
so that like it helps
boost the productivity
and helps them with
making decisions, right?
And then like start embedding AI
in all of our like design, development,
process improvements,
in the lifecycle of our
products and services.
And then evolutionary, right?
So continue to evolve this,
start like looking
for the next horizon intelligent systems.
Look at like do some experiments
and keep innovating, right?
And so, and how are we
enabling this, right?
So yes, the strategy is great,
but how are we enabling this?
Following the path of Cloud 3.0,
we started building this AI/ML platform
and providing a toolkit for the teams
to be able to start like
looking up like models
that's already available for them,
giving them a UI to help
create the workflows
for their use case,
or provide them one-click solutions
to convert their APIs to
MCPs, or like for agents.
And then like add in all
the observability part of it
to detect like model
drifts, auto-restraining,
and give it all as part of the platform
so the teams would be able to focus more
on building these agents
for their use case
or leveraging the agents, existing agents,
for like their use case
to start delivering
value for the business.
So what we had seen,
the benefits out of that
is application teams were
able to build their agents
for the use cases, rag
models, like their MCPs,
anonymous agents, whatever, right?
So they were able to build this like
from the time got reduced
from weeks to days, right?
So we saw that 80% improvement in teams
being able to kind of quickly
churn out like what they need
and trying it out, trying it out.
And today we have more than 50+ models
running in our platforms,
and about 200 of our applications,
like 10% of our applications
like having like AI capability.
And so what is the value
for the business, right?
Like these are some of the use cases,
like successful use
cases, success stories,
where like we had seen
AI being like put to use
to solve a very specific problem,
and it was done in a
very quick way, right?
The contact centers,
the team, they launched
a care CoPilot, a customer care CoPilot,
which could help in looking into the cases
that like we get
submitted by the customers
through the portal or
through sending an email
so that we had this AI agent
start like looking into these emails
and start looking at how
they've been solved in the past,
how the service agents
were able to address it,
and start like responding to that, right?
So we saw like the
resolution time coming down,
and like now today we are
like able to resolve it
or resolve like issues
and like two times faster.
And another success story
is the flight updates.
Whenever the flight gets delayed
you would've seen getting notifications
saying your flight is delayed.
So we used to create those
notifications very manually,
and on a bad day we were able to do that
for 15% of our delayed flights,
because like there are like people sitting
and looking into all of the systems,
finding out what really happened,
and curate that story and send it out.
But today we have like
AI agents doing that,
and we are able to send it
out for 50% of our flights,
and also we are getting into sending
more personalized messages, right,
saying like, "Hey, your flight is delayed,
but don't worry about your connection.
You're gonna be able to make it."
So we are able to get
it from a flight level
to a passenger level notifications.
And on the technology side,
we are able to bring
in, leverage AI, right,
like running in these
platforms for like code assist,
code development, code fixes, testing,
and we are already started
seeing 15% efficiency
in our the development time, right?
So again, so what's the journey?
The next step in our journey
is to push the boundaries
of this AI, look into frontier models,
so aligned with our like
data, domain, language,
and start looking at agentic efficiency
through multipurpose architecture,
and also like start looking
at autonomous agents,
which could take decisions,
decisions like that the
humans would do, right?
So this has basically kind of set us up
to start reimagining our business
in a much bigger, bolder way.
So like to thank Infosys
for this opportunity,
and I want give it back to Gopal.
Thank you much.
(audience applauding)
- Thank you. Sure, good.
Thank you. Thank you so much.
Thank you for being here.
I know this is probably the
last session of the day.
I wanna take a moment to
thank each of our speakers,
Keisha, Srini, Sada, and Krishna.
Amazing stories, fantastic transformation.
We've seen each of them embrace Cloud
to create scalability and resilience.
They've modernized their applications,
they've gotten their data ready,
they're all ready for
delivering amazing experiences
to each one of us.
So all of these companies
touch us every day.
They touch our lives every day,
and we are really looking forward
to seeing amazing
experiences being generated.
Thank you again. Thank you for being here.
We are gonna be out here
for a few more minutes
in case you've got questions.
Otherwise we hope to see some of you
at our reception happening,
starting at six o'clock in the evening.
Thank you again for coming here.
Thank you for each of our
speakers for being here.
Thank you for the partnership.
Thanks, AWS, for this opportunity.
Thank you.